شكرا خديجه وبالتحديد هذا الفيديو سيكون
محل ايضا نقاش وبحث في هذه الفقره
العسكريه اذا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في
النافذه الجديده للتحليل العسكري لمجريات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف
اللواء فايز الدويري المحلل العسكري
والخبير الاستراتيجي ونتابع ايضا اخر
تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه
التفاعليه مع الزميله سلام خض ونبدا معك
اذا سلام شكرا سين
اذا تطورات متسارعه في قطاع غزه وسير
المعارك على وقع طبعا تصريحات
اسرائيليه من بني جانس الذي يقول ان ان
اسرائيل تستعد لحرب طويله وممتده الى
تصريح دانييل هاجار المتحدث باسم الجيش
الذي يقول بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يدفع
خسائر كبيره جدا في هذه الحرب واثمان ضهض
لكن نستمر بالقتال من هذه هذه النقطه
سنبدا في البريج اليوم كان هناك البريج في
وسط قطاع غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن قبل
يومين انه سيوسع من هجماته باتجاه هذه
المنطقه منطقه المخيمات جنوب مدينه غزه
البريج اليوم شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه جدا
ومستمره كتائب القسام وايضا فصائل
المقاومه استهدفت في البريج اكثر من قوه
اسرائيليه وايضا مدرعات ودبابات ميركافا
دمرتها في منطقه البريج وتقول ان
الاشتباكات فيها مستمره وتسير بشكل متصاعد
وحتى الان القوات الاسرائيليه لم تتوغل
بشكل كامل لم تنهي مساله البريج وما زالت
تقاتل عند تخومه طبعا البريج هو سهل
الوصول اليه لا يبعد كثيرا عن الحدود اقصى
نقطه ايه ل من بين نصف او او مركز مخيم
البريج والحدود لا تزيد على كيلومتر ونصف
تقريبا وبالتالي التوغل اليه صعب وايضا
التراجع عن ما يجري في البريش صعب هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه اشتباكات قاسيه عمليات
مستمره ومكثفه تشهدها
و صحيح كما قال دانييل ها جاري ان اسرائيل
تدفع في هذه المنطقه اثمان كثيره سواء على
صعيد ال الجنود او على صعيد الاليات ولكن
التطور الوحيد لم يكن جنوب مدينه غزه
المدينه نفس المدينه نفس مدينه غزه
والشوارع المؤديه اليها شهدت تطورات على
المستوى الكمي وايضا على المستوى النوعي
سنبدا من المستوى النوعي اليوم قالت كتائب
القسام انها اسقطت مسيره اسرائيليه من نوع
سكايلارك اثنين هذه المسيره مطوره عن
النموذج الاول و سكايلارك هي طائره تجسس
تستطيع الطيران لفتره قد تصل الى ست ساعات
ومزوده بالات تصوير بالبث الحي لحظي
ويمكنها ان تلتقط صورا عاليه الدقه حتى في
اقصى الظروف الجويه سواء كانت ضباب او حتى
مطر شديد القسام استهدف هذه الطائره
المسيره في تل الزعتر وايضا هذه المناطق
اليوم التفاح
والدرج مناطق اشتباك قويه جدا بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي
والمقاومين يفترض ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
عندما توغل ووصل الى احياء داخليه في
مدينه غزه ان تكون
الخلفيه هذا
الجيش يعني محميه ولكن التوغل غير محمي
وهناك خسائر دفعتها القوات الاسرائيليه
سريعا سن ننهي في الجنوب الجنوب خان يونس
ما تزال هي موضع الاشتباك الاساسي اليوم
القسام قالت انها استهدفت تجمعات جنود
واستهدفت اليات القتال فيها مستمر على
اكثر من محور وحتى الان لم تستطع القوات
الاسرائيليه دخول قلب مدينه خان يونس زين
هذه ابرز التطورات الميدانيه وسط وشمال
وجنوب القطاع التحليل معك والجنرال دويري
شكرا جزيلا لك سلام خضر وسنبدا مع سياده
اللواء فايز الدور نرحب بك مره ثانيه
ونبدا من هذا الفيديو الخاص بمخيم بمنطقه
البريش مخيم البريش الذي ادعنا قبل قليل
وتحدثنا عنه من قبل لكن هذا الفيديو طبعا
يبين استهداف
اليات وياتي في سياق تحدثت فييه كتاب
القسام اليوم عن استهداف ت اليه اسرائيليه
ما بين دبابه وجراف وناقله جند
وايضا من بين الاليات
سبع دبابات ميركافا ما هي ملاحظاتك
المبدئيه على هذا الفيديو و وايضا على
حقيقه انه في البريج الذي انضمت اليه
الفرقه 36 مدرعه يا سيدي يعني الفرقه 36
تم الدفع بها قبل تقريبا يعني يومين كانت
مقاربتها العسكريه مختلفه كانت تحاول
للدخول ما بين البريج والمسيرات ولكنها
فشلت فاختارت تغيير ش نعم اختارت تغيير
شكل المناوره وهاجمت خاص انه المناطق من
الشمال والشرق والجنوب للبيج هي ارض
زراعيه فتوقعت ان تكون الامور اسهل ولكن
دخلت في منطقه يبدو انها ليست من السهوله
الدخول بها فجاءت هذه صوره مختصره تمثل
الواقع هذا يعني قد يكون هناك استهداف
لاربعه اليات لكن الحقيقه في هذا اليوم ت
19 اليه منها سبع دبابات ميركافا وهذا
ضريبه باهظه يدفعها الجيش وهو حتى هذه
اللحظه لم لم يدخل البريج وكما قالت يعني
هذا القتال في المناطق الزراعيه التي تقع
الى نقطه ما شمال شرق جنوب البريج
وبالتالي هذه المنطقه يوجد فيها لواء
الوسط يطلق عليه لواء الوسط موزع الى عده
كتائب سواء في البريج او في المغازي او في
نصيرات وغير ذلك ويعتبر من الالويه ذات
السجل الحافل في المواجهات السابقه ويكتب
عنه بانه قوه متميزه وقد تكون مقاربه الى
حد ما الى لواء خان يونس الذي يخوض معارك
ضاريه جدا وهذا عباره عن تصوير لبعض
اللقطات لانه لا اعتقد ان بامكان القسام
ان يصور كل العمليات العسكريه هو ابو
عبيده في كلمته قبل قليل قال ان هذا غيض
من فيض لكن هنالك ارقام ايضا في كلمه ابو
عبيده اي ارقام تتعلق بتدمير
825 اليه وطبعا هو الفيديو يقول فيه هنالك
اشاره زمنيه ايضا لتوقيت تسجيل الفيديو
حينما قال 83 يوم انه بعد 83 يوم نعم يعني
هو الفيديو يبدو انه سجل في هذا اليوم
وبالتالي لكن هل سجل قبل هذا الرقم 19 اذا
اذا لم يكن اذا كانت هذا الت التسجيل
سابقا على الاعلان فالرقم الان 844 4 وليس
825 لانه يجب ان نضيف رقم 19 فيصبح
المجموع 844 الاليه وهذه القسام والان
لاحظ في البيانات اللي بتصدرها
القسام استهداف استهداف استهداف هذا اللفظ
له تفسيره في بعض الحالات الاصداف قد يكون
ادى الى اصابه قاتله اصابه جزئيه في بعض
الحالات قد يكون اخفاق فيها وهذا احتمال
وارد وبالتالي هو الحديث الان عن عمليه
تدمير بغض النظر تدمير كلي او تدمير جزئي
اذا اضفنا لها
المعدات اللي دمرتها بقيه الفصائل الجهاد
وغيرها تجاوز عتبه الالف اليه عسكريه
عسكريه بغض النظر وهل هذا بالنسبه لما
يحوز عليه جيش الاحتلال من اليات يعتبر
عددا كبيرا يعني الان عندما نتحدث عن هذا
الرقم اذا اذا تحدثنا عن الرقم الالف هذا
معدات ثلاث فرق هذه معدات ثلاث فرق
وبالتالي الان عندما بدات تطلب
استعاده بطاريه القبه الحديديه بدات تطلب
طائرات اباتشي بدات تطلب بالامس طلبت
تزويدها بالقطع الغيار سبير باتس للدبابات
الميركافا طلبت ذخيره 120 ملم للدبابه
الميركافا طلبت ذخيره التل الام تل س
وبالتالي يعني هذا يضاف له 320 طائره قبل
اربعه ايام 20 سفينه ويضاف له مخزونات
امريكيه موجوده في اسرائيل والاتفاقيه لمن
يشاء يعود ويقراها هناك اتفاقيه تتيح
لاسرائيل الاستخدام المباشر للمستودعات
الامريكيه داخل الكيان دون الطلب ويضاف
الى ذلك 63 قاعده عسكريه بغض النظر عن
حجمها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط و 810 قواعد
امريكيه حول العالم كلها مسخره والخط
الثالث والخط الثاني الجيش الامريكي هذا
الموضوع كله تحت تصرف الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا يعني ربما يصيب الكثيرين ب
الاندهاش على الاقل نهيك عن الصدمه عندما
نتحد لكن لكن المعركه ليست
يعني لا يمكن لهذه الاسلحه ان تستخدم
جميعها في هذه المعركه يا سيدي معدل وزن
الذاع الحمم التي تسقط على قطع غزه المعدل
العام وهذه دراسات قدمت
1000 طن فاحن نتحدث عن 80 ال طن من
المتفجرات ماذا يعن هذا الرقم العالم اهتز
له عقود يهتز على ما جرى في هورشيما
هورشيما 15000 طن ناجازاكي 25000 طن غزه
83000 طن ما القي على ه ما القي على
هامبورج وبقيه المدن الالمانيه خلال اربع
سنوات من الحرب العالميه الثانيه العيه
الثانيه لا يكافئ الرقم الذي القي على غزه
وبالتالي ا جمله واحده يعني انت تحدثت بان
هذا الكم هائل جدا ولكن هذا هذا الاستخدام
هذا الافراط في استخدام القوه كم دمر من
غزه 80% من من من ابنيه قطاع غزه دمرت
وغير صالحه للسكن كم وهل افاد شيئا في
المعركه لم يحقق اي انجاز عسكري فق فقط هو
الرغبه في القتل والتدمير من اجل التهجير
وهذا لن يتحقق في قراتي ا ناتي الى نقطه
مهمه وهو ما اعلنته كتائب القسام اليوم من
اسقاط مسيره مسيره استطلاع اسرائيل اللي
هي سكايلارك اثنين ا وهي طبعا احنا تحدثت
عنها السلام وتحدثنا عنها لكن هذا يطرح
سؤال حول قدرات
المقاومه محك هذا الاستخدام هذا الاستخدام
دعني اكمل فقط السؤال لانه كيف تفعل
اسرائيل كل ذلك لانه ليس هنالك دفاع جوي
في في غزه
ا قديما كان كان لا يوجد شيء سو الرشاشات
والقنابل اليدويه الان صواريخ المقاومه
تصل الى كل تغطي كل فلسطين ا نحن الان
نتحدث عن استهداف لطائره مسيره تم اسقاط
هل يمكن ان يكون نواه
لتطوير سلاح دفاع جوي الان كافه معظم
الاسلحه يعني دعني اقول معظم الاسلحه
وليست كافه الاسلحه هي انتاج محلي في
الانفاق من خلال الهندسه العكسيه لكن
كانوا يعني حتى الطائرات المسيره الزواري
وغيرها ابابيل واحد هي ذا طائرات تصنيع
محلي تبقى مشكله الدفاع الجوي بانه اكثر
تعقيدا عمليه اعتماد الهندسه العكسيه يعني
تواجه تحديات كبيره لماذا عندما نتحدث عن
صاروخ نتحدث عن صاروخ يطلق ارض ارض
وبالتالي هناك احتماليه الخطا وهي مقبوله
ان تكون يعني في بعض الحالات الصواريخ
الروسيه سكود درجه الخطا تصل الى دائره
500 متر اذا عمليه المحاكاه لهذه الاسلحه
تكون سهله سهله الان عندما نتحدث عن تاندم
وياسين نتحدث عن مدى فعال 130 متر في حده
الاقصى اذا كذلك المحاكاه سهله عندما
اتحدث الان عن دفاع جوي الان عليك ان
تتعامل مع هدف يطير على ارتفاعات مختلفه
وبسرعه كبيره وبالتالي حتى الدول المتقدمه
لا تزال تواجه الان تحدي ديات وتجري تجارب
على على يعني على سبيل المثال ارو او ثاد
امريكا لا تزال تواجه اخفاقات وكذلك روسيا
اذا هم سيصل لها عاجلا ام اجلا لكن تحتاج
الى وقت ومزيد من الخبره انا فقط يعني
اسال السؤال يعني اريد ان اتخيل هذه
المعركه في غزه اذا كان هنالك دفاع جوي
لدى المقاومه الفلسطين يعني هو لو كان في
دفاع جوي في غزه هل يجري في غزه ما جرى لا
لكن غزه رغم انها محاصره الم يشر في هذا
اليوم ابو عبيده الى الى اعاده تدوير او
استخدام الصواريخ التي تنفجر ودمرت خمس
دب اشكرك شكرا جزيلا الواء فايز الير
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي